Internet secretary Ryan Zaki today will
decide the fate of several national
monument areas federal protection for
places like Utah's bears ears or
California's giant sequoia monument
could be rolled back or eliminated the
issue is part of a larger debate going
on about the future of public land under
the trump administration now in the West
the federal government owns and manages
almost half of all public land think
about that public land in the whole
country totals about six hundred and
forty million acres some people want the
government to let go of that land Jeff
Glor traveled throughout the West to
find out why Jeff good morning Nora good
morning to you some believe more federal
land should be turned over to States or
private buyers but there is little
consensus on how when or if that should
happen in January Utah Republican
congressman jason Chaffetz introduced a
bill calling for the sale of 3.3 million
acres of federal land in 10 western
states backlash from a wide coalition of
conservationists hunters and ranchers
killed the bill but not the debate in
northern Idaho on land that seems
destined to slide into a picture frame
ranchers herd cattle surrounded by
storms and sagebrush this unit is a
summer range this is ground that Jim
Hagan barse family has managed since the
late 1800s
much of it federal there's millions of
federal land here we used to work with
the federal land agencies hand-in-hand
and we're our wonderful team getting a
lot of things done the federal
government still owns nearly 62 percent
of the land in Idaho just over 63
percent in Utah and about 80 percent in
Nevada we're violating the American
promise and we're reaping the
consequences in Utah the legislature has
been very clear but today a fervent
group of advocates and conservatives
including Utah state representative Ken
ivory say the status quo should change
is the federal government doing a bad
job managing the land in Utah it's
terrible because they're treating the
land like it's a museum right that lock
it up hands off don't touch it makes no
sense to have a distant unaccountable
non-transparent bureaucracy duo one size
fits all hands off don't touch
management policy ivory says the federal
government which owns nearly half of all
land in the West should get out of
management altogether one of the
criticism says that you just want the
federal land to go to the state so that
you can eventually transfer it to
private buyers in some way yeah I mean
the the people that want to hyper belies
and scare people that's where they go
you don't want to do that well no you
because again going back there are there
are rights and interests and
expectations that you have to maintain
those well how do you do that do you do
that from a federal bureaucrat that's
unelected that doesn't care or do you
have County Commissioners with local
land use plans preserve and maintain
those rights and interest well that's
what we're looking for
Pat Tierney represents the Greater
Yellowstone coalition one of the groups
that believes dicing up federal land
could eliminate access for the vast
majority of Americans since states or
private owners would not carry the same
obligations why do you think it's so
important for public lands to stay
public well we all use these lands to
hunt to fish to camp and it's a big part
of teaching our kids our outdoor
heritage the folks who advocate for this
say can be managed even better on an
even more local level that the state can
do a better job than the federal
government I think they're blowing smoke
it's an issue for now where many
conservationists and ranchers have found
common ground a lot of people might be
surprised that a big rancher like you
would say luck the federal land keep
everything don't leave that stuff alone
let's manage it I'm saying let's manage
the federal land so as has a healthy
social economic and ecological structure
States haven't got the budget to manage
says there are millions acres out here
that's a daydream and this ground
belongs to mother nature that rock right
there is gonna be there in 10 million
years long after we're gone Hagen Bart
says that state control would result in
higher costs not lower conservation and
tribal groups have purchased a blitz of
ads hoping to influence this debate
zenki is expected Secretary's Inc he is
expected to make his decision by today
but that doesn't mean the administration
will release it right away I'm so glad
we did this story so interesting yeah
anyone - we have no time for reaction
but I agree with mr. Hagan birther with
the hat more to come
the land belongs to Mother Nature's is
our life that's right what do you got -
yep thanks